on behalf of Rotten Tomatoes 93%
yeah heretics have rated t2 fresh whoo
you get a certified fresh' award I get a
certified first twenty six years later I
think I think not only didn't you exist
but Rotten Tomatoes didn't exist and
that's why we're doing it now pretty
damn cool right I didn't know that you
guys did retroactively award hell yeah
we do well for this survey alright cuz
that's what's great about getting to see
a movie again especially in 3d mm-hmm
it's like I knew this movie was great
but now I get to re-experience it right
in a whole new way so I was wondering
when you went back and watched it for
the purposes of converting it yeah
was there one thing that you were really
excited for audiences to see in 3d is
there something you could mean yeah well
look I mean the the the physical
presence of these big trucks and
machines and and and the terminators
motorcycle yeah it's just you feel you
feel the power you feel the mass of
these juggernauts and it's sort of
because they're always an expression of
character you know Arnold's character he
has to ride the biggest motorcycle drive
the biggest and and the same thing with
Robert Patrick's character the t1000 you
know it's all about machines with badass
machines you know against us poor little
humans that don't stand a chance I've
always I've spent my life fascinated by
t1000 hands yeah and those in 3d are so
amazing well that's actually a really
nice point when that needle comes out of
his fingertip or when the blade comes
through the door yeah we had some fun
with that yeah but I mean I think the
trick to a good 3d whether it's authored
natively with 3d cameras or whether it's
a conversion is to never kind of make it
a gimmick but always make it organic
you know you want it to be present you
want it to be strong but you don't want
it to distract you in the in the moment
well right I mean because it's about
enhancing yes that makes sense yeah
so our rule was only ever add value and
if the 3d becomes taking away from the
scene
we just need to dialed it down or in a
couple of cases we just didn't do the
shot in 3d
oh there you and you'll never notice
because there are so many depth cues in
a shot even when it's actually flat that
your mind just flows right through it
anyway yeah because I mean in in
watching the movie in 2d it already felt
it's a very three-dimensional to begin
with and that's a credit to the shooting
of it well I think it's a certain style
you know more wider lenses certain types
of compositions where you've got
something in the foreground the
mid-ground the background when you've
got multiple characters in a scene and
they're all sort of composed in a way
that it's very conscious of the depth so
it actually was a sweet film to convert
because a lot of the 3d depth cubes were
already there and he there yeah mostly
works done well well I wouldn't say that
I think the thousand artists that work
for six months on the stereo might take
exception to fair enough ya know that
that's actually a theme that I see in a
lot of your films and so is there any
kind of sneak peek as to another one of
your movies that you want to convert
that you haven't well I mean I think
it's a question of personal we have to
prove the business model we we proved it
with Titanic but Titanic was in a kind
of class of its own right if we can
prove it with t2 and we don't know yet
then we might look at let's say aliens
which I think he still has a strong fan
base and it's also a film that in the
way that it was shot I think
fit in 3d and also your episode of Dark
Angel please thank you yeah I actually
really liked that episode yes yeah
you're talking about the season finale
for year two yeah yeah I like that
if you could pick maybe any film from
history you know just outside forces
notwithstanding to see in 3d is there a
movie that comes to mind oh okay it
would be my list of the films that I
love you know anything from Casablanca I
would love to see Casablanca in 3d that
would be cool
how about 2001 a Space Odyssey in 3d
going through the slits can you know the
Stargate yeah that'd be pretty damn
awesome how about a gladiator you know I
mean you know there are a lot of there
are a lot of pretty great films that the
problem is that that the you know I mean
obviously really Scott could do
gladiator if you wanted to but Stanley
Kubrick's not around you know and all
the other big big filmmakers that I've
that I've admired David Lean and so on
they're they're not around so then you
get into the ethical question of should
it be done by someone else after that
after the fact and yes you can do it I
think if it was a I think if it was a
fellow filmmaker of of stature that
loved 3d and didn't do anything to goofy
like make gimmicks out of things but
just but just did it nice it's almost
like a restoration and I'm sure I
started kind of how I thought of t2 3d
we did a 4k transfer from the original
negative and then denoise that so it's
just it's crisper and clearer and
snappier than the 70 mil prints were in
91
so you're seeing something that's never
been seen before even before we get to
the to the 3d now so many filmmakers
since you've been responsible for
creating some of this groundbreaking
technology have wanted their films to
catch up and even surpass what you've
done and most recently a lupus on did
valerian and he mentioned you said I
want this visually to like be even
better than the best thing we've seen
which is you know the technology in
Avatar wasn't use some of the same
people in some of the same tech to
create the the pearl people that work on
a central to the story would you do I
don't want to say do you have any advice
for them but do you have any comment on
that or any kind of encouragement for
people that want to create and surpass
what you've created yeah look I mean I
don't know you know Luke Luke is a
friend and a colleague I know what he
was going for what he was yearning for
with all his heart and it wasn't
embraced by an audience and I've had
films that weren't embraced by audiences
even though I was proud of the part of
the film so I know what that I know what
that feels like I mean it look it's the
quest that we're all on as filmmakers to
find that story and those characters
that resonate with the audience and then
and then get the right actor to inhabit
that character and I don't to say it's
luck but man you look back on you think
I got lucky I got lucky with Linda
Hamilton on and with Arnold Eddie
furlong I mean you look at that cast and
you think well they're those people you
don't even think of them as the actor
anymore I I don't get the character it's
the character the character when the
character takes on a life of its own
separate from the actor even years later
then you know you've sort of achieved
something in the zeitgeist and they've
achieved the actors achieve something
for sure and I have to get out of here
but really fast Sarah Connor
orna teary on your fighting team oh boy
well look Neytiri would probably kick
Sarah's ass because she's about twice
her height on the other hand Sarah's
pretty mean with that pump shotgun so so
shout out to my tall girls yeah yeah
exactly the tall girls role but I don't
know in a depth first of all they
wouldn't fight each other they'd be on
the same side so it's kind of pointless
there you go great but they might get
they might get drunk and brawl a bit you
know just be fun
[Music]